κάπου κάνεις καθημερινά τα δύο να βγάζουμε προς τον κόσμο για να τα ξέρει ο
κόσμοςσματα φικτράρι να δει τι έκανες ιτάξει κοιτάξει και τορωτα αυτόν επειδήσουν και δήπλα από
τον νίκων αναστασια ναι δεν είναι θέμα ποσωτικό είναι θέμα προγραμματισμού σε κάποιο παθμό και
τα υτό χρονα η στην επικοινωνία ι επανάλειψεις είναι μήτι πάσεις μαθύσιως όπως έλέγαν οι
αρχιίμονπρόγωνι πρέπει να επαναλαμβάνει σε ένα μήνειο οι έρευνες έχουν δείξει ότι ο μέσως πολί
της αρχίζεηνα κού ι ένα μήνυμα στην έκτυμη στην έβδομη φορά που θα το επαναλάβες
τούτι η κυβέρνησης λέει μέσα σε μία ενημέρα πέντε διαφορετικά μηνήματα την άλλη εναι μέρα
λέει περιάτι άλλαταη μηνήματα ρα δεν κολλά κάτι στον στο ψηβοφόρο σύνεπως ναι χρειάζζεται περισσότερι
επικέντρο ης χρειάζεται καλύτερος προγραμματισμός και λιγότερι ακούεται παρί περίεργον αλλάλιγότερι προσπάθει δηλαδή τω να
προσπαθεί στόσον πολ βγάσεις και μιαν αχωνία να θέλισ γι αυτό το π ο νικός
αναστασιάδει από γανετι συμβολές το αντρια χασιρες ώρες ώρεςώρες ιτάξει δεν έχει υποκοίταξευπάρχει να περιστατικό
που θημάσει από ότι από τις υεργασιά που είχες με τον νίκο ανάστασιάδ που το
έλεγες πρόεδρε μην το γανεισ αυτόν και με να το γάο να σουπότερα όότόταν είσαι
σύμβουλος σε πολιτικά πρόσωπα πρώτα πο λλα πρέπει εσί ως άτομον ναδεκτίσω ότι στο τέλος
της ημέρας αυτός ο οποίος βγαίνει προστά αυτς οποίος εκτίθεται αυτός οποίος ζητάτι ψύμφων του
κόσμου δεν είς εσι ενω πολιτικώς άρα ο ρόλος ωτικός σου τελειώνει το ναδώσει της
συμβουλή στο δώσεις της συμβουλήσουν να μη γίνει κάτι ήνα γίνει κάτι και αννιώθεις πάρα
πολύ έντωνα για κάτι το οποίο παναλαμβανωμένα δεν γίνεται τα παίρνεις και φύκης άρα σίγουρα
στην περίψωση του υθα μπορούσαν να σου πω ότι οένας κας